THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> KANYE WEST MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPARKING A MEDIA
FIRESTORM A QUICK REFRESHER OF
WHAT WENT DOWN YESTERDAY.
>> YOU KNOW, THEY TRY TO SCARE
ME TO NOT WEAR THIS HAT.
MY OWN FRIENDS.
BUT IN HAT, GIVES ME POWER IN A
WAY.
WHEN I PUT THIS HAD ON, MAILED
ME FEEL LIKE SUPERMAN.
IF HE DON'T LOOK GOOD WE DON'T
LOOK GOOD.
THIS IS OUR PRESIDENT.
HE HAS TO BE THE FLIEST, THE
FLIEST PLANES, I LOVE THIS GUY
RIGHT HERE.
LET ME GIVE THIS GUY A HUG.
[LAUGHING]
LY ON HAVE THIS GUY RIGHT HERE.
>> Dana: THE SITDOWN SETTING OFF
CNN'S DON LEMON.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK, DON?
>> WOLF, LISTEN, I DON'T -- I
HAVE NO ANIMOSITY FOR CAN TE
WEST.
WHAT I SAW -- KANYE WEST.
WHAT I SAW WAS A MINSTREL SHOW,
HIM IN FRONT OF ALL OF THE WHITE
PEOPLE EMBARRASSING HIMSELF AND
EMBARRASSING AMERICANS, BUT
MOSTLY AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
IT WAS SO HARD TO WATCH.
HIM SITTING THERE BEING USED BY
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Dana: LEMON TAKING HIS
DISAPPROVAL FURTHER, INVOKING
THE RAPPER, HILLS LATE MOTHER --
HIS LATE MOTHER.
>> AN EMBARRASSMENT.
KANYE'S MOTHER IS ROLLING OVER
IN HER GRAVE.
I SPOKE TO ONE OF HER FRIENDS
TODAY, TEXTED WITH ONE OF HER
FRIENDS FROM CHICAGO, I USED TO
LIVE THERE.
SHE SAID DANDA WOULD BE
EMBARRASSED BY THIS.
SHE WOULD BE TERRIBLY DISTURBED
BY THIS.
HE NOODZ A FATHER FIGURE, SOME
ONE TO HELP HIM, GUIDE HIM, HE
NEEDS TO HUG MORE THAN ANYTHING.
KANYE, BACK AWAY FROM THE
CAMERAS, GO GET SOME HELP, AND
THEN COME BACK AND MAKE YOUR
CASE.
>> Dana: OTHERS IN THE MEDIA
BLASTING THE KANYE-TRUMP SUMMIT.
WATCH THIS.
>> THIS IS SUCH A BLITZKRIEG OF
BLATHERRING IGNORANCE, AS A MAN
WHO LOVES KANYE WEST, WHO
ADMIRES HIS GENIUS, AND
CONSIDERS HIM A FRIEND.
>> THIS IS THE KIND OF
CONVERSATION THAT WOULD
TYPICALLY HELD BETWEEN PEOPLE
WEARING HOSPITAL BRACELETS.
>> A DEEP SENSE OF BETRAYAL
AMONG PEOPLE WHO FOLLOW HIP-HOP
AND RAP.
>> THIS WAS A GIANT, SHINY
OBJECT IN THE OVAL OFFICE
WEARING A RED HAT.
>> IF YOU THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
GET THOUGHTFUL PLAY-BY-PLAY AND
POLITICAL ANALYSIS YOU ARE NOT.
THAT WAS AN ASSAULT ON OUR WHITE
HOUSE.
>> WHY GIVE IT THE HYPE, WHY FAN
THE FLAMES OF THE FOOLISH?
AND IT'S NOT OKAY WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
>> Dana: CELEBRITIES CRITICIZING
KANYE, FELLOW RAPPER T.I.
POSTING, THIS IS THE MOST
REPULSIVE, DISGRACE WHY, ACT OF
DESPERATION AND AUCTIONING-OFF
OF ONE'S SOUL TO GAIN POWER I'VE
EVER SEEN.
OTHER HOLLYWOOD STARS, CHELSEA
HANDLER, ROSIE O'DONNELL
SLAMMING IT.
BUT WE WANT TO GET TO THE
DISCUSSION.
JESSE, HYSTERIA, OVER THIS
MEETING, WAS HOT AND HEAVY.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
SO, IF KANYE IS SO MARGINALIZED
AND SO INSIGNIFICANT AND SUCH A
CLOWNIES THE MEDIA SO ANGRY?
WHY ARE THEY SO UPSET?
HE'S INFLUENTIAL, BECAUSE HE'S
MAKING A LOT OF MONEY, HE'S VERY
TALENTED.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE LISTEN TO
HIM, HE'S POPULAR.
IF THE BLACK COMMUNITY IS
OPEN-MINDED ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP, THEN THAT POSES A
SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO DEMOCRATS
ELECTORALLY.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE WRITTEN OFF
THE WHITE WORKING CLASS, WRITTEN
OFF VETERANS, THEY HAVE WRITTEN
OFF A KEY CONSTITUENCY WITHIN
THE PAR THINK.
EF -- PARTY.
THEY HAVE TO DRIVE UP NUMBERS
WITH MINORITIES TO SAY THERE
WITH DONALD TRUMP IN 2020.
THIS ISN'T GOOD FOR THEM.
YOU REMEMBER WHEN KANYE WEST
SAID GEORGE BUSH DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE.
THE SAME MEDIA THAT IS
CRITICIZING HIM NOW APPLAUDED
HIM THEN.
WHEN YOU CRITICIZE, A BLACK MAN,
A REPUBLICAN YOU'RE SANE.
AND THEN WHEN YOU SPREAD LOVE TO
A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT YOU'RE
INSANE?
I DON'T LIKE HOW THAT WORKS.
DONALD TRUMP WON ABOUT 8% OF THE
BLACK VOTE.
DOES THAT MEAN ALL THOSE 8% OF
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE CRAZY?
THEY'RE IG NOMPBT?
THEY'RE ALL FOOLS?
IGNORANT?
WOMEN WHO VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP
ARE THEY GENDER TRAITORS?
HISPANICS?
WHEN THE MEDIA SAYS THAT VOTING
AS A BLACK MAN FOR DONALD TRUMP
IS AGAINST YOURSELF INTERESTS,
WHO ARE THEY TO DETERMINE WHO IS
SOME ONE'S SELF INTEREST.
WHY CAN'T BLACK AMERICANS
DETERMINE THEIR OWN SELF
INTEREST BY THEMSELVES.
WHY DO THEY HAVE TO HAVE THE
LIBERAL MEDIA TELL THEM WHAT TO
DO.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT ON BALANCE,
DONALD TRUMP'S TRADE AGENDA,
MANUFACTURING AGENDA,
IMMIGRATION EVEN GENTLEMAN, IS
BENEFICIAL TO BLACK VOTERS.
POLICY-WISE.
AND YOU CAN DISLIKE HIM FOR
OTHER THINGS, THAT'S FINE, BUT
ON BALANCE IT'S FAIR FOR BLACK
AMERICANS TO SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT,
I CAN CONSIDER THE TRUMP AGENDA.
>> BACK IN 2005, AT LEAST IN THE
LAST -- RECENT PAST, KANYE WEST
APOLOGIZED FOR SAYING THAT.
>> Juan: I WAS SOME ONE HIGHLY
CRITICAL WHEN HE SAID THAT ABOUT
PRESIDENT BUSH.
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
HERE YOU COME, WHY CAN'T BLACK
PEOPLE BE OPEN-MINDED ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
GUESS WHAT, JESSE, BY YOUR OWN
MEASURE 92% OF BLACK PEOPLE SAID
OUR SELF INTERESTS IS NOT BEING
SERVED BY THE AGENDA BEING
PROMOTED BY THIS PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: HE CAN'T THINK FOR
HIMSELF?
>> Juan: IF HE WAS THINKING FOR
HIMSELF HE WOULD HAVE HAD SOME
SUBSTANTIVE ARGUMENT TO MAKE.
INSTEAD HERE'S WHAT HE SAID,
JESSE.
OH, I POUT THIS HAT, AND IT
GIVES ME SUPER POWER.
I REALLY WANT A FATHER FIGURE.
THEN HE SEPARATED BY THE DESK,
HAS TO WALK AROUND, HE'S THERE
HUGGING TRUMP LIKE HE'S HOLDING
ON.
HE'S TRYING TO GET SOMETHING OUT
OF THIS.
>> Jesse: JIM BROWN --
>> Juan: LET ME FINISH.
YOU HEAR THIS MAN, SAY STUFF
LIKE, TRUMP IS ON A HERO'S
JOURNEY.
MAYBE HE'S ON A FOLLY.
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT IT ALL LOOKED LIKE, SOME GUY
RANTING, AND I AM, PERSONALLY
OFFENDED, BY THE KIND OF
PROFANITY HE BROUGHT.
THERE I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
ANYBODY WOULD TOLERATE THAT.
I DON'T GET THIS.
WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE
COMMON, JAY-Z, KENDRICK LAMAR
DOING THINGS WITH PRESIDENT
OBAMA THE RIGHT WING WENT NUTS,
THEY SAID THEY'RE RAPPERS, SOME
OF THEM ASSOCIATE WITH THUGS AND
BEGANSTERS.
WHAT ABOUT THIS GUY?
THE MAN WHO INSULTED
REPUBLICANS, THE MAN WHO HAS NO
TO SAY OTHER THAN HIS HAT GIVES
HIM SUPER POWER IS A REPUBLICAN
HERO?
THIS IS RIDICULOUS, ABSURD.
DON LEMON, AMEN.
THIS IS SOME ONE WHO IS A
SHAMEFUL EXAMPLE OF BEHAVIOR IN
THE PRESENCE OF A POWERFUL WHITE
MAN.
>> Jesse: IT WAS SHAMEFUL HE
WENT AFTER HIS MOM LIKE THAT.
>> Juan: HE DIDN'T GO AFTER HIS
MOTHER, HE SAID HIS MOTHER WOULD
BE ROLLING OVER.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS A CHEAP SHOT.
>> Juan: YOU DISTORT THIS RGS
CONFIDENCE.
THIS WAS NOT ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE
OR HIS IMPACTS ON THE BLACK
VOTE.
THIS IS HOW WHITE AMERICANS, WHO
SAY, HEY, TRUMP HAS PROBLEMS
WITH RACE, FEEL ABOUT TRUMP.
NOW TRUMP SAYS, HEY LOOK,
AMERICA, I HAVE A BLACK FRIEND
IN A RED HAT.
>> Dana: THE REASON I WAS
LOOKING LIKE THAT, WE HAVE TAPE
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> President Trump: FROM TURKEY,
IN GOOD SHAPE, HE WILL BE
STOPPING IN GERMANY FOR A FULL
CHECKUP, AND THEN HE'S GOING TO
BE COMING TO THE OVAL OFFICE,
MOST LIKELY, ON SATURDAY.
BUT WE'RE VERY HONORED TO HAVE
HIM BACK WITH US.
HE SUFFERED GREATLY BUT WE'RE
VERY APPRECIATIVE TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
SO PASTOR BRUNSON IS IN THE AIR,
HEADING TO GERMANY, AND THEN
COMING TO THE U.S.
HE WILL BE LANDING ON SATURDAY,
MOST LIKELY SATURDAY IN D.C.
>> WHAT IS THE RELIEF,
MR. PRESIDENT?
>> President Trump: WELL, WE
SPOKE TO TURKEY.
AND HE WENT THROUGH A SYSTEM,
AND WE GOT HIM OUT.
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET HIM
OUT FOR A LONG TIME.
[INAUDIBLE QUESTION]
>> President Trump: THIS HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH ANYTHING, NO
DEAL WAS MADE AT ALL, NO DEAL.
BUT WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO HAVE
HIM.
AND HAVE HIM IN GOOD SHAPE.
I HEAR HE'S IN VERY GOOD SHAPE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT ARE YOU
REEVALUATING THE RELATIONSHIP
WITH SAUDI ARABIA?
>> President Trump: WE'LL FIND
OUT WHAT HAPPENED WITH RESPECT
TO THE TERRIBLE SITUATION IN
TURKEY, HAVING TO DO WITH SAUDI
ARABIA, AND THE REPORTER, AND
NOBODY KNOWS QUITE YET, NOBODY
HAS BEEN ABLE TO PUT IT ALL
TOGETHER.
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO FORM
IDEAS.
AS THEY'RE FORMED WE'LL LET YOU
KNOW.
BUT IT CERTAINLY IS A TERRIBLE
THING.
>> HAS THEIR RECORD BEEN
OVERLOOKED FOR TOO LONG?
>> President Trump: A LOT OF
RECORDS ARE OVERLOOKED IF YOU
LOOK AT IRAN, IF YOU LOOK AT SO
MANY OTHER COUNTRIES, SYRIA, A
LOT OF COUNTRIES, A LOT OF
COUNTRIES' RECORDS HAVE BEEN
OVERLOOKED.
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS THING AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT IT IN A VERY
SERIOUS MANNER.
AND WE'LL SEE YOU, WE HAVE A BIG
CROWD.
>> HAVE YOU TALKED TO THE KING
OF SAUDI ARABIA?
>> President Trump: I HAVE NOT.
I WILL BE CALLING HIM.
I WILL BE CALLING AT SOME POINT
KING SOL ON MOP, YOU'RE RIGHT IN
A WAY.
I'M SURE THEY THINK YOU'RE A
GOOD LOOKING GUY.
MAYBE NOT THAT GOOD FROM THE
BACK, RIGHT?
>> YOU PLAN TO CALL HIM --
>> President Trump: I WILL BE
TALKING TO HIM.
>> WHAT THE CONVERSATION BE
LIKE?
>> President Trump: THEY ARE
LOOKING HARD AND FAST, A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO FIND OUT.
IT'S NOT JUST US.
IT IS POTENTIALLY A TERRIBLE
SITUATION.
SO WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> WAS IT A MISTAKE FOR JARED TO
DEVELOP A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP?
>> President Trump: I DON'T KNOW
THAT IT'S ANY CLOSER THAN OTHER
RELATIONSHIPS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF RELATIONSHIPS
WITH A LOT OF COUNTRIES.
BUT THIS IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
THANK YOU.
[QUESTION INAUDIBLE]
>> President Trump: A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE GOING OVER TO AN
INVESTMENT CONFERENCE.
HE ACTUALLY CALLED THIS MORNING,
AND HE WILL MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION.
BUT HE WAS PARTIALLY OVER THERE
ANYWAY A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE GOING
OVER TO THE INVESTMENT
CONFERENCE.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
MAYBE SOME WON'T BE GOING.
WE'LL MAKE THAT DETERMINATION
VERY SOON.
WE'LL SEE YOU OVER AT THE RALLY.
.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKING
ABOUT PASTOR BRUNSON, THE
AMERICAN WHO WAS RELEASED FROM
CAPTIVITY, BEING HELD BY THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT, AND NOW HE
IS GOING TO BE RETURNED TO
AMERICA.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE SHOULD BE
BACK IN D.C. BY SATURDAY.
PROBABLY SATURDAY, A SFO IN
GERMANY FOR A CHECKUP, THEN
RETURNING TO AMERICA A BIG WIN
FOR THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE GLAD
THAT PASTOR BRUNSON IS BEING
RETURNED TO AMERICA.
SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN HELD IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
BACK TO THE STORY WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT, JESSE AND JUAN
HAD A CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT KANYE
WEST MEETING IN THE OVAL OFFICE
AND REACTION TO IT.
GREG AND JEDEDIAH HADN'T HAD A
CHANCE.
SGG GOOD NEWS ABOUT THE PASTOR,
WHEN YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
DOESN'T BLINK.
THEY KNEW HE WASN'T GOING TO
CHANGE HIS MIND.
>> Dana: AND THE ECONOMY IS IN A
FREE FALL.
>>> Greg: I WANT TO ADDRESS THE
CENTRAL ARGUMENT THAT LEMON AND
OTHERS HAVE, WHEN YOU DESCRIBE
SOMEBODY AS A MINSTREL OR A
PROP.
I'VE LEARNED IN MY LIFE, ANY
CRITICISM THAT CAN BE APPLIED
EVERYWHERE IS USELESS.
IT'S POINTLESS.
FOR EXAMPLE, I COULD JUST AS
EASILY LOOK AT DON LEMON AND SAY
WOW CNN PULLED OUT THEIR PROP,
THEY NEEDED SOMEBODY TO TALK
ABOUT KANYE, SO THEY CALLED UP
THE BLACK GUY.
YOU CAN USE THIS.
YOU CAN USE THIS ON "THE FIVE"
WITH JUAN, I CAN CALL YOU A PROP
BUT I WOULD NEVER DO THAT.
THIS SORT OF CRITICISM CAN BE
APPLIED ANYWHERE THERE ARE
BLACKS AND WHITES TOGETHER.
THAT'S MY POINT.
WHEREVER YOU SEE AN OLIVE BRANCH
BETWEEN A BLACK PERSON AND A
WHITE PERSON, SOMEBODY CAN SAY,
HA, THE WHITE IS USING HIM AS A
MINSTREL AND THE BLACK IS
SEEKING POWER.
YOU CAN SAY THAT FOR EVERYTHING.
THAT'S WHY IT'S DANGEROUS, WHY
NOT JUST TAKE IT FOR WHAT IT IS.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING PEOPLE
ACTUALLY 6G A DIALOGUE, WHEN YOU
REDUCE SOMEBODY TO A MINSTREL,
OR YOU MAKE -- OR YOU HAVE THE
GAL TO ACTUALLY BRING UP HIS
LATE MOTHER TO MAKE A POINT,
USED HIS LATE MOTHER AS A VESSEL
FOR YOUR OWN ENVY, WHAT I SAW
THERE, I SAW LEMON, A PERSON,
WHO FELT INEFFECTUAL, HE'S NOT
PART OF THE GAME.
HE SEES WHAT'S ON GOING ON IN
THE WHITE HOUSE, LEMON IS SAYING
WHY CAN'T THAT BE ME, THAT'S NOT
FAIR, I SHOULD BE THERE.
HE WENT AFTER THIS GUY, BECAUSE
THIS GUY HAS THE GUTS TO STAND
UP AND TAKE THE SLINGS AND
ARROWS.
IF CNN WERE AROUND 2,000 YEARS
AGO, THE C WOULD STAND FORS
CRUCIFY HIM.
>> Dana: JEDEDIAH WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT THE COMMENTS HE'S
MENTALLY ILL, THAT FELT OVER THE
LINE.
>> WHAT BOTHERS ME, THEY HAVE
INFAN TALLIZED KANYE.
HE'S SUCCESSFUL, A SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESSMAN, NOT TALKING
NONSENSE, STOP AND FRISK, HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT WHAT HE CARES
ABOUT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ALL OF THE
CELEBRITIES THAT WENT INTO THE
OBAMA WHITE HOUSE, YOU THINK
THEY WERE ALL POLICY EXPERTS?
THEY WENT IN AND SAT DOWN, DANA
PERINO?
NO, THEY HAD AN OPINION, THEY
CARED ABOUT ISSUES, THEY WENT
IN, THEY MADE THEIR CASE.
THE CRITICISM FROM THE RIGHT WAS
NOT PERSONAL ATTACKS OF THOSE
PEOPLE.
IT WAS NOT SAYING THINGS WHICH
HAVE BEEN SAID ABOUT KANYE THAT
HE'S DUMB, HE'S SICK, HE'S A
MADMAN, A TRAITOR.
PEOPLE WERE SAYING, FOLKS ON THE
LEFT, WERE GOING IN, CELEBRITIES
ON THE LEFT GOING IN TO MEET
WITH OBAMA AND ALL THAT, THE
COMMENTARY WAS, WELL THIS IS
TYPICAL, BECAUSE DEMOCRATS AND
HOLLYWOOD ARE HAND IN HAPPENED.
NO ONE WAS GOING OUT THERE AND
SAYING PERSONALLY, GEORGE
CLOONEY IS MENTALLY UNSTABLE.
THIS IS OVER THE LINE.
THIS IS BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
HANDLE DISSENT.
THEY CAN'T HANDLE DISSENT.
SOME ONE WHO HAS LIVED IN
NEW YORK CITY HER WHOLE LIFE, I
WENT TO COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY, I
TAUGHT IN LIBERAL ACADEMIA, WHEN
YOU STAND OUT, THERE IS A
PATTERN ON THE LEFT OF HAVING TO
MARGINALIZE THAT PERSON, HAVING
TO POINT OUT THERE'S SOMETHING
WRONG WITH THEM, DRIVE THEM OUT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO RUIN THIS
GUY'S CAREER.
AND RUIN HIS CREDIBILITY.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO STOP AT
NOTHING.
I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT
WHETHER I AGREE WITH KANYE OR
NOT THAT TYPE OF BEHAVIOR SHOULD
NOT BE ACCEPTED.
>> Juan: GREG, I DON'T WANT IT
TO GO WITHOUT COMMENT, I DON'T
THINK I'M A TOKEN.
>>> Greg: THE SEE THE POINT.
>> Juan: I DON'T AGREE, NO ONE
WOULD SAY THAT TO YOU.
I DON'T THINK GIVEN MY RECORD
THERE'S ANYWAY YOU SAY, OH, JUAN
WILLIAMS IS SUPERFICIAL.
GS I'M TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
LOOKING AT COLOR, OH, THERE'S A
BLACK PERSON AND A WHITE PERSON.
>> Juan: YOU AS A WHITE PERSON,
I WOULD SAY, LISTEN, THIS IS
WHAT JEDEDIAH IS LOOKING AT,
LET'S MAKE A JUDGMENT.
WHEN I LOOK AT THE SUBSTANCE I
SAW NOTHING BUT A PUBLIC REWHAT
ISES OPPORTUNITY.
PUT ON BY THE PRESIDENT.
MAYBE KANYE DECIDING IT HELPS
HIS REPUTATION.
>>> Greg: I AM THE TOKEN SHORT
PERSON.